-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and now, if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
Happy New Year, everyone!
Tonight is our first show
of 2023.
It was going to be yesterday,
but I was on Southwest, so.
[ Laughter ]
The House held it's vote today
to elect a new speaker
and went to multiple ballots
for the first time in 100 years.
It's the moment every member
of Congress fears --
having to work longer hours.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set tomorrow
to promote
the bipartisan infrastructure
bill at an event in Kentucky
with Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell.
That's right, America's
crumbling infrastructure
is going to promote the
bipartisan infrastructure bill.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC is warning
that a new variant
of the Omicron strain
of coronavirus
has nearly doubled
over the past week,
so, it looks like COVID
is the only thing
that's actually doing
new year, new me.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans took control today
of the House of Representatives
for the first time
in four years.
Well, the first
legal time in four years.
[ Laughter ]
George Santos was sworn in today
as a member
of the House of Representatives
in the state of New York
and, not as he
originally claimed,
Pandora.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
We had a moment backstage.
We were like,
"Do we think everybody's
up to speed on the
George Santos story?"
[ Laughter ]
Been two weeks.
Everybody's with family.
They're not going to be reading
the news every day.
And now we know.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys know "Avatar"
came out?
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
was reportedly DJing
on his iPad
at Mar-A-Lago last week...
[ Laughter ]
and played Celine Dion's
"My Heart Will Go On."
[ Laughter ]
Wow, the guy definitely knows
how to get a party started.
[ Laughter ]
What'd he play at midnight,
"Everybody Hurts" by R.E.M.?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Of course,
no one hurts more than I do.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Trump was DJing on his iPad
last week at Mar-A-Lago
and I think the legal bills
are piling up for him
because every song was followed
by a Spotify ad.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
Just a few quick words
for my friends at Spotify.
[ Laughter ]
According
to newly released testimony,
former First Lady Melania Trump
was upset
that Rudy Giuliani was allowed
inside the White House residence
and was worried about him seeing
her wearing a bathrobe.
Or, 1,000 times more likely,
her seeing him in one.
[ Laughter ]
New York state's first licensed
marijuana store opened last week
in Manhattan at 4:20 pm
and it must be good weed
because it was supposed to open
at 10:00 am.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, yesterday was
National 55 mph Speed Limit Day,
or, as it's called
in New Jersey,
the texting lane.
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue,
everybody. We're off!
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's a new year!